Salut à tous et bienvenue pour ce nouveau Master Class'.
Le Samedi c'est le jour du Master Class' celui-ci est un peu différent des autres, j'avoue.
Mais il va être aussi une bascule entre ce qui c'est passé jusqu'à maintenant et la continuité de cette chaîne.
Peut-être avez-vous remarqué que depuis le premier janvier, depuis le lancement de la chaîne,
j'essayais de faire une espèce de progression pédagogique dans ce que je vous offrais.
C'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je ne réponds jamais aux questions du type
"Vas y apprends nous ça", "fais nous ça",
si c'est pas cohérent avec la chaîne.
Pourquoi ? Excellente question, merci de l'avoir posée.
Parce que je n'explique que ce que vous pouvez refaire.
En vrai je me prends pas pour un formateur ou quoi que ce soit.
Je n'ai pas du tout cette prétention.
Mais j'essaye que vous puissiez avoir une progression au fur et à mesure.
Par exemple tout ce que j'ai fait sur la mémoire peut s'assembler au fur et à mesure
pour faire grossir ça en espèce de savoir global.
Pareil pour le mentalisme, pareil pour les maths, pareil pour tout ce que j'aborde.
J'essaie de réfléchir.
Et arrêtez de vous dire, bah on dirait pas !
Peut-être avez vous remarqué, en tout cas j'espère, qu'on commençait quand même
à passer des paliers dans les explications du dimanche par exemple, dans les masters class.
On touche des choses qui sont de plus en plus sensibles, de plus en plus complexes à faire.
Et pourtant ça ne vous paraît pas complexe puisqu'on a vu plein de choses avant.
Un exemple concret, c'est la vidéo de dimanche dernier
pour deviner le prénom auquel pensait quelqu'un dans une soirée.
Je vais continuer la chaîne dans cet état d'esprit évidemment, on va encore passer des paliers.
Mais juste avant ça, je pense qu'on est au point d'équilibre
où on devrait pouvoir aborder un truc tout bête
qui nécessitait d'après moi un master class,
c'est se sentir bien soi-même.
Comment on fait pour se sentir vraiment bien intérieurement ?
C'est même pas forcément heureux, c'est juste libre, hein
qu'on ait pas de boule au ventre, pas de poids qui traîne quelque part émotionnellement.
Quand on aborde les notions de développement, de mentalisme, même de mémoire, même de culture,
je me dis que c'est super qu'on s'ouvre à plein plein de choses,
mais c'est bien de se recentrer sur soi pour se libérer soi-même et être heureux.
Ça rejoint d'ailleurs un petit peu ce dont je parlais mercredi dans la vidéo sur l'oral.
J'ai lu énormément de livres là dessus.
Il y en a un qui m'a marqué plus que les autres.
Il est très accessible. C'est le livre des 4 accords toltèques.
Je vais pas vous détailler tout le contenu du livre.
Déjà parce que ça se fait pas et je vous recommande plutôt de le lire.
Et c'est pas un placement de produit. J'ai pas d'action chez les 4 accords toltèques.
J'ai même pas d'action chez les toltèques d'ailleurs !
Mais je vais citer 4 choses fondamentales qui peuvent vraiment vous aider
et qui moi ont été une petite révélation quand j'ai lu ça.
Le premier accord que vous pouvez passer avec vous-même,
c'est de faire en sorte que votre parole soit impeccable.
Et ça c'est le plus dur. C'est très dur de rendre sa parole impeccable mais alors ... ça fait un bien fou.
Alors ça englobe plein de chose : le fait de pas mentir, le fait de pas critiquer les autres.
Je vais juste vous donner une métaphore qui est magnifique.
L'auteur du livre explique que dire du mal de quelqu'un,
c'est un petit peu comme si on versait du poison dans un verre,
qu'on le buvait soi-même et qu'on espérait que ça fasse mal à l'autre personne.
Cette image est très pertinente et très révélatrice de ce qu'est une parole impeccable.
Le 2ème accord que vous pouvez passer avec vous-même,
c'est de ne jamais en faire une affaire personnelle.
Ce que font et disent les autres à votre sujet ne vous concerne pas.
Ça les concerne eux-même.
C'est d'ailleurs la position que vous avez face à celui qui n'a pas une parole impeccable.
Si quelqu'un me dit "écoute Fabien, tes vidéos c'est nul, c'est nul, c'est nul, ...
... arrête, c'est tellement pourri ce que tu fais, ça ne sert à rien"
et bien je ferai tout pour mentalement et émotionnellement, ça ne me concerne pas.
Pourquoi ? Parce que c'est son problème à lui.
C'est lui qui a décidé de trouver ça nul. Et en fait, pourquoi il trouve ça nul ? Ça le renvoie à quoi ?
C'est tout un processus intérieur à lui, qui lui appartient
et qui est sûrement relié à ses propres angoisses, à ses propres peurs ou à ses propres attentes
mais c'est son affaire à lui, c'est pas la mienne.
Et bien d'un manière générale, dans la vie, n'en faite pas une affaire personnelle.
Le 3ème accord, c'est de ne pas faire de supposition. Ça complète un petit peu le 1er accord.
C'est un petit peu la formule magique. Il faut que vous arrêtiez de supposer à la place des autres.
C'est-à-dire de penser à la place des autres.
Ça n'a rien à voir avec le fait d'être déductif,
et de prendre les éléments tangents pour comprendre une situation.
Ça a juste rapport avec le fait de supposer pour tout à tort et à travers.
Que ce soit en amitié, en amour, professionnellement,
on passe notre temps à faire ça, à tirer des plans sur la comète et à se planter.
Ne faite pas de supposition, ça vous permettra de pas vous alourdir encore une fois émotionnellement pour rien.
Le 4ème accord, je vous laisserai le découvrir dans le livre si vous voulez le lire.
Il y a aussi toute l'introduction qui est très intéressante.
Toute la philosophie toltèque aussi est très bien.
Je vous ai vraiment extrait les 3 choses que je trouve vraiment essentielles
et que moi j'ai gardé à la lecture il y a des années de ça.
Ces 3 règles là, elles peuvent vous aider vraiment à ... pfff ...
... à s'alléger un petit peu de certaines angoisses et tout ça
et à retrouver un petit peu un état,
je vous ai dit c'est pas vraiment un état de heureux mais un état de bien-être.
Au moins être bien, c'est-à-dire ne pas être mal !
Ça parait logique hein dit comme ça, j'en ai conscience !
C'est un petit qu'est pas très long, qu'est en format poche. Je vous mettrai le lien dans la description.
Je me suis dit que j'allais vous parler de celui-là plutôt que d'un autre.
J'aurais pu vous parler d'Eckhart Tolle, le pouvoir de l'instant présent.
J'aurais pu aussi vous parler de la trilogie du bouquin de Walsch mais là,
c'est aussi un peu plus compliqué à aborder au départ.
Si vous connaissez déjà les accords toltèques, y a d'autres livres qui sont cool comme Hoʻoponopono
mais c'est un peu plus Shepherd donc il faut connaitre un peu tout cet univers là.
Et c'est un avis perso, y a pas de souci avec ça.
Je crois que pour aller plus loin dans le mentalisme,
il fallait juste qu'on se mette d'accord sur l'utilisation du mentalisme
qui est une utilisation légère, divertissante,
pour soi-même, pour un développement aussi de soi.
Mais le mentalisme, c'est pas fait à la base pour prendre aux autres ou pour manipuler
ou pour se glorifier auprès des autres.
Partant de ce principe là, il est important d'être en accord avec soi-même.
J'espère que ce Master Class un petit peu différent, un peu original vous aura plu.
Je me demande un peu comment vous allez le recevoir.
Ce sera un des seuls sur cette thématique là qu'il y aura sur la chaîne.
Mais j'espère qu'il vous apportera une ou deux phrases marquantes
et que vous irez lire le bouquin sur internet ou dans une bibliothèque ou que vous vous le ferez prêter
et faire vos propres conclusions bien sûr hein.
Y a pas d'obligation d'admettre ça ou de trouver ça cool. Mais lisez le, c'est intéressant.
Je vous souhaite un excellent week-end.
Demain, c'est l'explication de tour que j'ai pas encore écrite donc je sais pas encore ce que je vais vous faire demain.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'oubliez pas le 1er accord du Mental Vlog
qui est de mettre des pouces en l'air !
Vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne bien sûr.
Merci à vous tous d'être présent. Merci à tous ceux aussi qui font les sous-titres, vous assurez comme des chefs !
Le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an donc rendez-vous demain à 11h. Ciao !